And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
Remember, if you have questions during the Zoom call that you think of,
you can either voice them in or easiest to chat them in to use that chat box,
but feel unmute yourself and voice it in.
Everybody is muted.
When you come on your chat, you'll have to unmute yourself.
But otherwise just type it into the chat box and we will get to it.
For reminder that you can see any new announcements for the week on your home page of the member site.
Any new information I put like anything that even been discussed or something
that I thought would be good for everybody that wasn't done.
The Zoom call might put that on the home page of the member site to so look for that.
Also reminder you can self-schedule any calls, city personal calls with me that you need to do as well.
If you have a personal call that is of no cost, then you'll have to call it in schedule because this box,
this app that we use for the self-schedule won't let you self-schedule a free call.
So you have to call in and schedule that.
All right, first question.
High blood calcium.
So the person just put in high blood calcium.
So I'm thinking they're asking what does that mean when we have high blood calcium?
So calcium is a marker that will typically be tested in a complete metabolic panel.
It's obviously a measurement of calcium in the blood, which is a mineral.
Calcium in the blood acts as a buffer in the blood.
Remember we've talked about this in the past that you have a brilliant buffering system in your body.
That so the idea of, you know, we are, you know, going to alkalize ourselves by drinking alcohol and water.
We've talked about that.
That doesn't make any sense physiologically because of this buffering system.
Now we can be in a situation of acidosis or two alkaline.
And we're not buffering correctly, but that's not it because of we need to drink baking soda or we need to drink, you know, high pH water.
It's because of imbalances in our buffering system.
So high blood calcium or low blood calcium would be an imbalance in that buffering system.
And there'd be a reason for it.
So if a person had low blood calcium, it's usually a decrease in function gland that's called your, you're a thyroid gland.
Next to your thyroid gland in your neck, you have two little glands on either side that you had, that are called your para, be next to thyroid glands.
And they to create a hormone that balances the calcium in your blood.
So if you have an issue with that gland that can cause both high and low blood calcium.
It's a very common condition with the parathyroid gland.
It's a tuber of the parathyroid, actually quite common.
A tuber of the parathyroid gland typically produces high blood calcium.
So if a person does not have a diagnosis of cancer and they have all other normal values, but elevated calcium, that's the first thing that you want to investigate.
All blood work, all tests are just clues to something going on.
It doesn't always give you a definitive diagnosis, you have to dig into other things.
So you would do an MRI or CT scan of the parathyroid gland to see what's going on with the parathyroid gland.
Now, if a person has a diagnosis of cancer and they have elevated calcium levels, the parathyroid gland is not the first thing you think of.
The first thing you think of is a metastasis to bone.
So if a person has a diagnosis of cancer and that cancer metastasis to bone, it's typically going to be lytic and it's going to have destruction of that bone and spill calcium from that bone into the blood.
Now, typically it would also follow that in this same complete metabolic panel, that person would also show elevated alkaline phosphatase.
So that would be the other clue that you would look for.
So a person shows high blood calcium, you'd look for alkaline phosphatase.
If that's elevated also, then you'd think of destruction of bone and if a person had cancer, you'd think of metastasis.
And that's what you would look for.
But if the person had no previous diagnosis and they just showed elevated calcium and it spared the alkaline phosphatase.
If alkaline phosphatase was normal, then you'd think of parathyroid gland, hope that helps.
What can be done for eye brands, itching?
Eye brands, so if you have a side effect of a medication and eye brands is a medication that is used for breast cancer.
So a side effect of a cancer medication, you're just going to have to deal with the symptom itself.
So for instance, there's a lot of side effects in use of immunotherapy medication for all sorts of cancers because it causes basically a person to start to develop autoimmune disorders.
There's various types.
And how do you deal with that?
Well, you can't make those things go away.
You're just dealing with the symptoms.
So one thought in the natural world is let's help with detox pathways to help get rid of that medication so you don't have the side effects.
The negative of that is then you lose if you actually achieved that outcome.
You will be detoxing the medication so it wouldn't be working as well on the cancer.
So I would caution that thought process.
So if you're taking a medication for a disease and it's working for the disease and you have side effects from that medication,
and you've chosen to take that medication, then you're just going to have to deal with the symptoms of the side effects.
And when you're dealing with itching from a medication, you think of it's causing an allergic reaction to you think of you could take things to help decrease histamine levels.
You could take things topically to decrease histamine levels from a medical doctor.
They may give you a prescription for steroids from an alternative doctor.
They may give you things like clear histamine scavenger to help decrease that you could try over the counter into histamine things like that.
I wouldn't like trying to really ramp up detoxification processes because while it may work, it would also hinder the reason why you're taking the medication in the first place.
Next question.
The tube I have has some loose crystals that are moving around. Is this something that needs to be fixed?
So the crystal hammer bulbs are those crystals are adhesed on with some type of glue adhesive and know they do as they as it bounces around in there.
Things will break off and that is just that is not something that can be repaired.
Now, remember prior to there being any existence of the crystal hammer bulb, there's a lot of people that may be listening to this call there like what is this person talking about?
I don't have crystals on my tube.
There's more of a recent addition with the rife technology is with the tubes to have them sprayed crystal sprayed on them.
It gives some advantages. I talked in other videos, some advantages of using a crystal bulb versus a non crystal bulb.
So, but the negative is that you're going to get little pieces that break off and there's nothing to do.
So there's nothing harmful about that. It is. It's not everybody. So there's nothing to be done about that.
Also, sometimes during a program, the tube gets very hot. Is that normal? Yes, it is.
So at different frequencies, the tube is going to get hotter. That's why at different nights, you'll go home. The tube wasn't even hot tonight.
And then other nights that you're running it, it gets really hot. That is normal. Just try to cool it off by maybe removing it from the covers.
There's times with me I know that if it kind of gets stuck underneath my side and I fall asleep with it in a certain position, because there's less air flow around the tube, it gets hotter.
So there's different reasons why it gets hotter. But big part is the frequencies that are running at a particular time.
That is normal and there should be anything to worry about with that.
Other right-fishing, there are three different detox programs. Could you explain them?
Would I get similar benefits as if I were doing detox supplements if I were to do the programs?
Good question. So the different detox programs that are on the right, but if you search, there's lots of detox programs on the right.
And there's different detox frequencies in your overnight program.
So there are what's different about them? What's different frequencies that have been discovered that will help deliver or help the kidneys with detox?
Now different people will feel like certain programs work better for them than others. They feel better. They run XYZ program.
And they don't feel the same when they run a different program. You're just going to have to experiment with those.
Are they similar as doing a detox supplement? Yes, but it's different. So a detox supplement may be specifically supporting a certain pathway from a nutritional standpoint.
You're using frequencies to support different pathways. I always think it's better if you can just use frequencies.
It's quicker. You don't have to purchase a product.
If you're taking a product, even a great herbal product, let's say it has to go into your stomach and into your testicle track.
And then you have to absorb it and it's a circulator on the blood and get to the area that you're trying to affect.
So if you could just use frequencies, it's better.
So I always think the right should be your first go to after saying that you shouldn't do detox supplements or do supplements for different things.
Say if you have an infection or something, I'd always say at least get started on the right immediately.
So if I got a sore throat, run the sore throat program. If you have symptoms of something, at least be running the right right away.
You shouldn't do other things, but they can be coupled together and you could even get better results.
Do you have doctors, functional doctors or naturopaths that you would recommend in a soda.
If I have other health issues, I would like to go to someone familiar with your work.
No, just use us. So if you have other things, other comorbidities, just call and make an appointment with me and we'll go over that.
So we could go over anything you want to go over.
So just use you are already using me. I already know your history.
Just communicate with me and that goes with your family members too.
So a daughter who's got menstrual issues or something, that's fine. Just make an appointment with me with her.
Another case review and we'll go over it and discuss different therapies and things.
Remember, all the courses are open to you too. So you should have access to all the courses and the reason why I created those courses is so that I could refer people to something of that course.
I do that often. Oh, I'm having all these memory issues of county thinking and stuff and I can refer them to a video on the course or they're having issues with their thyroid.
We're going to refer you to the autoimmune course, the last section of the autoimmune course is all about the thyroid.
So if I can't help you put something beyond my school, then we can try to find somebody that could help you with something that you need help with.
So there is there is a functional that I wouldn't call them functional MDs but they're very.
In Minnesota, there's a kingdom health that we refer people to who need a prescription for something because they are very friendly to our work.
They refer us a lot of patients actually, but you know, you only need to go there if you need to get something that we can't provide like a medical prescription.
Let's say a person has strepthrone or something and they do want to get an antibiotic, well, then we'll send them over there.
But use us call and schedule a little boy with me. I'll go over all sorts of non cancer things with you as well.
Have you read the science behind blood type diets? Do you have any thoughts on whether this is legitimate or wacky?
So I remember when that blood type diet book came out, there was back in the 80s, I think, good to say for a long time ago, I read that book.
There's a lot of it that was very interesting. I can see how it's extremely appealing to a lot of people.
I can just see if I have a type A type B type O blood type that I can see what I should eat.
And some people I've had I had patients over the years and said that really fit me perfectly.
I have a type A blood type and that means that I really shouldn't eat meat and I'm an out of vegetarian diet and I feel really great doing it.
Do I think it's legitimate? Honestly, no, I don't think it's legitimate at all.
Partly, the reason why I disagree with it is that he's basing all of his scientific evidence on blood type diets based upon what he believes of the evolutionary tree.
But I'm not a fan of I don't think it's correct and I don't think there's a lot of legitimacy about it at all.
In fact, it's kind of been proven to be a little hokey because I can't tell you how many people that, you know, it didn't fit.
It was the exact opposite of I do think that there's people that do better on eating less meat.
And I think there's people that do better eating a lot more meat.
But I don't think it has to do with blood type. I think it has to do with genetics.
So a person has a lot of bad gene defects that I'd say they probably don't do as well eating, you know, a high meat diet.
They wouldn't do well on a carnivore type diet.
But if a person has a lot of HIF1A defects, that's a gene.
At the end point, they're going calluses. They wouldn't do well on a vegetarian, you know, high carbohydrate diet.
So I think it has more to do with genetics than it has to do.
I don't think it has anything to do with blood type.
So that's why I opinion.
And a lot of questions that come in this week.
So I will get to these ones that you're chatting in. So keep chatting.
Next question.
I'm confused about the best time to take my Ivermectin and fed bed dissolve.
I had been trying to space my doses about 12 hours apart.
And you commented that it may be best to take the Ivermectin and fed bed dissolve separately.
So I tried to space them a few hours apart at that.
Now I'm reading that I should be taking these with food.
My eating window is typically nude to seven.
So should I take the protocol at nude and at seven?
Or should I ignore my eating window and just take a bit of food with these doses that are approximately 12 hours apart?
And do I still do the bulk of my eating in my seven hour window?
Yeah.
So it's hard.
Do I think you should take fed bed dissolve in Ivermectin?
First of all, at the same time.
Now maybe I commented that you should split them apart, but that was just an option.
So I don't know that you can't take them together.
Like if I'm taking 50 milligrams of Ivermectin and 22 milligrams of fed bed dissolve,
could I literally swallow them at the same time?
I think so.
I don't, you know, obviously I think it's better with all your supplements if you can split them up a little bit.
But we have to live in the real world too.
And you have to benefit.
You have to look at the benefit of I take it.
You're talking about an eating window.
You're talking about time restricted eating or intermittent fasting that you're trying to stick to.
Now, I will say that sometimes people that don't take that take fed bed dissolve,
at least at an empty stomach can feel a little yucky because it can maybe upset their tummy a little bit.
I've had that happen.
I also think that fed bed dissolve has been shown that it is better absorbed if you take it with a fat,
because it's not water, real water soluble.
It's more fat soluble drug.
So yeah, you kind of got to weigh these things out and what's going to be best for you.
It sounds like you're taking the Ivermectin and fed bed dissolve twice per day,
according to this question.
So yeah, I would say you want to make sure you're not feeling sick from the fed bed dissolve,
or the Ivermectin.
So eating some food and maybe getting some fat in your food for better absorption.
That would be more important than your eating window.
That's, I think that's what I would do is I would eat something with your dosage.
Next question.
What are all the ways that you are aware of to destroy a solid mass tuber other than conventional surgery?
Here's what I'm aware.
Cryooblation.
That's using cold therapy to destroy the tumor.
Radio surgery.
That's using radiation.
Microwave ablation.
That's using microwave current.
Now again, some of these are not even going to be available to people.
Microwave ablation.
There's a really deep video on YouTube if they haven't pulled it out.
I think it was Cleveland Clinic in the hospital.
Cleveland Clinic was doing microwave ablation of a breast tumor.
And it was pretty cool video.
They had great results.
Now I haven't heard anything about that since then.
So I don't know how much of that has been done really sadly because they probably can't charge you.
$100,000 for it.
And recently still in clinical trials is histotrypsy, which uses sound waves.
There's some really neat videos using sound waves.
It's kind of like hypersonic waves under a CT scan to show how you are destroyed tumor cells.
Really deep videos that I don't know when that will ever be out for real use.
So I don't know.
Are there any other procedures that I'm aware of?
Well, there's, you know, there's evidence that I would agree that using any of these and hyperthermia, I would add that to the mix can destroy solid tumor mass.
But it does they don't always even even with the best technicians and technology.
It's still not going to necessarily destroy that mass.
I know there was doctor C. Machini was doing injections of hydrogen.
What was he doing?
He was doing injections into tumor masses.
He was in Italy a number of years ago and he got thrown into prison for it.
I know of another doctor in Europe who did ozone injections near around tumor masses.
And he claimed to have some success with that.
Though I've had some negative things with that that have been done.
Zinc injections into prostate gland has been done.
Um, cases, really good results, some cases, no results whatsoever.
The truth is nothing is going to work 100% of the time.
It's just not so.
Yeah, I know that there's a lot of people trying different things and you and a lot of things are working and in a drawing attention of the medical establishment.
What example would be what questions you asked before about bed bed is all that I've ever mentioned it.
It's only because that there's been duorist success stories that the medical establishment has to start looking at these things.
It's really borsy their hand to start looking at those these things, though they put it made fun of it for years and years and years.
Same thing with Rick Simpson, well, they have to start addressing that these things actually can't work.
Um, and sometimes can work just as good or better and chemotherapy with less side effects.
I recently read a comment by someone using the Joe Tippins protocol again, the Joe Tippins protocol is the fed bend is all protocol.
That they stopped their fed bend is all because their liver enzymes increased.
We talked about that and our call last week and a couple weeks ago.
But then they learned that it the increase in the liver enzymes was due to cancer cell destruction.
Could that be true? How does cancer cell die off alter your labs?
Well, um, cancer cell die off let's say let's say you have a breast tumor.
Let's say it's not in the liver. So any tumor that's not in the liver.
Um, and you have die off of that of that tumor could it cause an increase in liver enzymes?
The liver enzymes that would be looking at would be AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase.
So understand when a cancer cell dies.
So when you're killing a tumor, killing a cancer, there are several different ways that cells can die.
One cell way, the normal program cell that is called apoptosis.
That's basically a recycling of the cell. The cell blems in on each on itself.
That's the term it's used blebbing.
And then it basically through the lysosomes breaks up the cell and recycles the cell matter.
And it's producing very little what's called endotoxins.
And endotoxin is a toxin that is now has to be detoxified through the liver pathways because of a cell death.
So in in apoptosis, there is very little endotoxin production.
So it is not going to overwhelm the liver or or hinder detoxification pathways or block detoxification pathways.
And the cell death through apoptosis is not going to increase ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase.
Second way, cancer cells die is through apathological cell death and that's set through cell lysis.
So that's like the cell just exploding because it's dying through pathological death.
And you can get some of this in you can get some apoptosis taking place through natural cell death like through the knife machine and through using herbs and through immune stimulation.
It's going to be mainly apoptosis.
But certain alternative therapies can cause cell lysis too.
So lysis is an exploding of the cell, it's not recycling of the cell material.
You're going to get a spillage of that cell material and then that cell material is going to build up in the in the extra cellular matrix.
Of fluid and waste that's around cells that is then carried through the lymph system back to the needle system and then carried through the liver and it has to be detoxified through the liver.
So what a cell explodes dies through lysis, it's going to produce a lot of endotoxins that that has to be detoxified.
So could that cause an increase in ALT, AST in alkaline phosphatase?
The answer to that is log explanation to the answer being maybe, usually not.
Usually what is going to cause an excess, it can make you, so what would that cause?
It could make you feel yucky when you have excess endotoxins, it could make you feel ill, it could make you feel fatigued, flu-ish.
But by overwhelming the liver detox pathways with normal toxins that the liver that is not poisoned to the liver, it will just deliver will reject it.
You know, the liver will have a no vacancy sign when blood is coming into it and trying to dump its waste.
So all this waste from cell lysis is going to have been carried through the lymph system into the blood system, have to go into the liver and if the liver is full it's going to put up its no vacancy sign and it's not going to accept that excess waste.
So if you had excess lysis like quick cell death, you could feel the effects of that, that waste in the blood being deposited in other parts of the body and it could cause fatigue, it could cause just bluish type symptoms.
That would be what would be called a herxide reaction. That's not going to elevate your liver enzymes.
What will elevate your liver enzymes? If your liver is injured, so excess waste that is natural, quote-a-quote waste products is not going to injure your liver, what would injure your liver is poisons.
So what would injure your liver? What could possibly injure one's liver if they're getting cell destruction, pathological destruction?
Using something that is pathologically destroying the cell, aka chemotherapy. So if the person is doing radiation or chemotherapy and causing cell lysis, it's not the cell lysis that's going to increase the cell, the decrease the liver enzymes.
It would be the chemotherapy or the radiation that would damage the liver and cause the elevation of those enzymes.
So I would disagree with this comment. I highly doubt if it was cancer cell destruction raising the liver enzyme cults.
Because cancer cell destruction, still, if you destroy a cancer cell, it's still your living tissue, it's still your old human tissue.
It's not a poison that you're destroying. It's not some enemy from outside. It's your old cells.
That's not going to damage the liver. The liver is damaged, it's injured. That's what you're going to have elevation of AST, ALT and alkaline phosphates in the liver, because if the cause of those raised numbers are from the liver.
I don't think so, so I don't think that's true. Even if it was true, even if that was true, that we could prove that that was a true statement, you still have to pause this therapy because you're damaging the liver.
Whatever is causing the elevation of the AST, ALT and alkaline phosphates cannot continue. You can't say, oh, it's just because you're killing cancer cells, so that's a good problem to have.
I can deal with it if it's a pain or if it's a symptom like that, but no, you could have liver failure and you could die from liver failure. No, you can't do that.
Regardless, it doesn't make any difference. You'd still have to pause the therapy. Now, I understand a lot of people are doing fed men while they're doing table therapy or doing something else. It might not be the fed men that's causing it. It could be the table therapy. It could be the other drug you're taking.
It could be that it literally could be the Tylenol you're taking. Do you realize that 15,000 people a year die of Tylenol poisoning? Well, how is that?
What? Because it causes liver toxicity. Guarantee you before they died of the Tylenol poisoning, they're elevated liver enzymes. There's lots of things that can damage the liver and most of the time it's going to be drugs.
So even though even a good drug that men is all great drugs to kill cancer, but it can in the liver. So you have to back off on it. So that's why you're going to do fed men.
You do Ivermectin. You're going to do anything like that. You need to be running a complete metabolic panel so that we can look at those liver enzymes. You don't want to take the chance of, oh, I just feel so achy because I'm killing the cancer. So that's a good thing.
No, we got to look at you feel achy because you're killing your liver and you could die of liver toxicity and die of liver failure from the therapy. Not a good thing. So we got to investigate those things. So promise me you'll look at that.
What are some guidelines for circumventing chemo induced neuropathy?
So so chemo induced neuropathy is when you're taking chemo again, it's destruction. So chemotherapy is trying to kill cancer cells, but also it's can kill other cells that are more susceptible to oxidative stress.
So remember chemo therapy is an oxidative stress therapy. So it's increasing oxidation. Well, that's a bad thing, right? No, what cancer is in an already in a state of relative oxidative stress compared to healthy cells. So when you add oxidative stress or it's like a poison like chemotherapy, you will tip over a cancer cell before you kill a healthy cell. Now you're going to kill some healthy cells, right?
And the healthy cells that you're more likely to kill is healthy cells that are more metabolically active, right? Because they're uptake, they're going to uptake the chemo more. So what are those your hair follicles, right?
That's why people lose their hair when they do chemo therapy. More metabolically active, they're going to uptake more chemo therapy, which is your immune system. So your immune system, your bone marrow is highly metabolically active. It's going to uptake the chemo more, and it's going to damage you. That's the huge catch 22 with chemo therapy is you're going to have a damaged immune system.
So that's why they test your white blood cell kelp before administer a chemo therapy dose because they can't let that get too low.
What else is highly metabolically active your neurons your neurons are highly metabolically active and your peripheral neuropathy is going to pool in the extracellular space in the extracellular matrix.
That's the that's the that's the cooling of fluid and waste around cells in your extremity. It's going to pool much more than in your core.
So you're going to have more damage to neurons in the extremity than you're going to have in the core. That is what is chemo therapy induced neuropathy.
So you have a greater chance of damaging the neurons in your extremities. So you're going to have lots of feeling that your fingertips and your hands and your toes and your feet.
That's chemo induced neuropathy. So what are some things that you could do to help with that?
Well, vitamin B. Yes, vitamin B is a good our good for your nerves. Yep, that would be good.
I mean, for neuropathy, no, I that would not be my first choice, especially glutamine.
If you have if you're dealing with colon cancer, I wouldn't use glutamine alpha low payac acid, that would probably help, but it would also negate the positive effects of the chemo therapy because alpha low payac acid is an antioxidant.
You're trying to take it to make sense. Let's take an antioxidant so we decrease that oxidative stress of my neurons.
You have it. You're also decreasing the oxidative stress of your cancer. You can't make the alpha low payac can't make the antioxidant just go to your fingertips. So yeah, that I wouldn't vitamin B six of all the bees would be probably the most applicable for the neuropathy.
Exercise. So this is what you get into different therapy. So exercise use of the nerves is the best. So nerves, the way nerve pathways function is through they need oxygen and they need to be fired.
So if you want to keep a nerve pathway, you need to keep firing that nerve pathway. Same thing with your brain. If you want to keep your brain alive, you got to keep learning new things you never stop learning you never stop thinking you never stop working your brain.
You're going to put your brain in pause mode because you're retired. That's when you're going to start to see, you know, dementia, happening, et cetera. Same thing with your peripheral nerves. That's where the that one tool that we have called the rebuilder, the rebuilder is a tool that is approved.
That is FDA approved for peripheral neuropathy. What it is, it stimulates at the at the frequency of the nerve. So actually put your hands in a bucket of water. It has to be a split bucket, not like your foot bath bucket.
And then you put one of the rubber pads in each side and you turn this thing on and you feel this tingle that's actually firing those peripheral nerves.
It really does work well. We've used the rebuilder for well over 10 years, 15 years. These did a lot when we were doing brain based therapy. It's extremely beneficial. We see a lot of peripheral neuropathy due to diabetes and it's extremely beneficial tool.
So think about getting a rebuilder. But exercise moving your hands, touching it, moving your feet, having stimulation on your feet and your hands, vibration plates are fantastic to stimulate peripheral nerve. So if you have, you can even buy an inexpensive foot massage vibration plate on Amazon for a couple hundred bucks.
Put your feet on that constantly. You can put your hands on that. Stimulating the nerve pathway, stimulating the sensory points in your hand and your feet is going to be key because you've got to keep those nerves alive because really what neuropathy is is damaged to the nerves that nerves are dying.
So that can happen from diabetes. So the most common cause of neuropathy is is, you know, to elevate a blood sugar and then chemotherapy. So those things.
At one point, after a chemo infusion to advise to return to coffee animals, I always say 48 hours. So 48 hours after your chemo infusion and foot baths. Pretty much, I would say 48 hours for that too.
Why do some medical folks say there's no evidence of coffee and it was work?
Because there's no money in coffee animals. I mean, they don't understand the neurology. I mean, most medical folks are only spewing out the data that the drunk companies gave them.
Unfortunately, there's very few people in the medical community that are self thinkers. And the ones that are self thinkers have left the medical community and they've started their own practices.
Those are the people that you see doing TikTok videos that are trying to help people with a medical license.
So, you know, just go back to understanding, you know, the parasympathetic response, the whole purpose of coffee animals to stimulate your parasympathetic nerves.
Okay, on your site, you advise fasting prior to having chemotherapy administered certain chemo such as full-fox required fusions that go across a period of 48 hours.
What do you recommend? What are your recommendations for fasting given that treatment? Also, when I asked the clinic advised against fasting as in lower blood sugars, it may result in nausea during treatment.
Well, there's multiple studies of fasting in chemotherapy and one of them asked one of them tested people fasting for 48 hours prior to the chemotherapy infusion and another fasted for 24 hours prior to the chemotherapy infusion.
And I know there's other practitioners that ask people to fast 24 hours before their infusion in the 24 hours after the initial intake of the infusion.
So, you wouldn't need to tell you got home maybe 18 hours after you got home.
I've always asked people to kind of cut it in the middle and just do a 24 hour fast prior to the chemotherapy infusion and eat what you get home.
Now, if you're doing the chemotherapy, the whole idea of that basically is to lower your blood sugar before you do chemotherapy.
Basically, if you could think of it as a cartoon, the cancer cells are much hungrier than your regular cells because they're more metabolically active because they're in a state of rapid replication.
There's a lot more going on in a shorter period of time inside of a cancer cell so they're burning a lot more energy and they're burning energy very inefficiently, not through the crem cycle primarily, but through the end point of glycolysis, which is an inefficient way to make energy because they're the cells are that is healthy as a normal cell.
So, they need a lot of glucose so they're gobbling up glucose so if you starve them for a half hour before 24 hours prior to chemotherapy, if you could think of it as they're super hungry, they're going to uptake chemotherapy more than a healthy cell will and that is kind of the theory behind fasting.
Now, all the research, whether they were doing 48 hours prior to chemo fasting 24 hours, 24 hours after or just 24 hours before all the research showed a decrease in symptoms by all the people that did it, a decrease inside effects of the chemotherapy.
And though you can't prove that they had better results because, you know, there's too many factors involved, I think you get better results because the chemos get a better chance of uptake in the cancer cell.
So, of course, if it's making you sick or something like that, you have to do what is going to be best for you, it's not a perfect number or anything like that.
But I think fasting for a period of time, however you feel comfortable fasting prior to that infusion, it's going to be better.
What do you do when you got 48 hour period of the infusion itself? Well, you're probably going to have to eat something during that time.
But again, eating small amount during that time is not going to give this giant fuel source to the to the cancer cells.
So you just have to do what you can do.
And but I think fasting prior to the initial infusion is going to be your best bet.
Also, this clinic is one doing 50 gram IV vitamin C infusions immediately after the oxaloplacum.
I am always advised to have food with the IV vitamin C, which further complicates fasting due to the IV vitamin C, also lowering blood sugars or so I understand.
So if they're doing it right after, I mean, again, if you did the 24 hour fast, you got the IV of the chemo, and then you're going to do the IV infusion of the vitamin C, you could be eating while you do that.
I mean, that's just one thought.
Really more about the Joe Tippen's protocol.
There is much discussion about the poor bioavailability of fed medizol. And here's an article. I read that article before I just find it funny how.
When there's all this natural excuse me, there's all this evidence from alternative doctors that something is working.
They have to go and try to throw a wrench at it. Well, fed medizol is not really water soluble and blah, blah, blah, blah. Well, I mean, maybe, yeah, I would agree. It's not water soluble. And but maybe, you know, with a person is taking, let's say the normal initial dose of fed medizol, 22 milligrams per day, three days on four days off.
Maybe it's all there only need 150 milligrams to help kill the cancer. It's a kind of nonsense about that. I would, I always try to take positives out of the evidence that is, that is, that is laid out.
And taking the positive out of that was that, okay, well, maybe you should eat a fat when you take your fed medizol.
Some people have gone even further and tried to mix the fed medizol in a, an oil like an olive oil or something like that and then swallowing it.
Kind of making their own liposomal fed medizol really doesn't work exactly like that. But if you just eat it with a fat, there, maybe you'll get better absorption of that.
So it's fairly inexpensive product and, and you certainly, that's maybe, maybe that's why some people go to higher doses of fed medizol.
But the argument with that is kind of silly because if there's, you can say that about any drug that's not readily absorbed, how much is the bioavailability of any medication that you're taking, you're only getting a percentage of it, the rest is being deposited in the toilet.
But they don't bash that. I just think it's kind of silly. I've had reading the research about Ivermectin combating breast cancer stem cells on your site from three, 24 and a few other places.
Do you think it would be beneficial to take Ivermectin pro-galactically or would this be something you would only try if you do breast cancer cells were present?
So there's a lot of people that take Ivermectin pro-galactically. Do I? No. So if you don't have cancer or let's say you're in a, let's say your cancer is in a state of remission, let's say you don't have cancer, or your cancer is in a good state of remission.
Person, I wouldn't keep taking Ivermectin. There are some people that take Ivermectin pro-galactically or other reasons. I mean during the COVID thing, a lot of people were taking Ivermectin pro-galactically.
The pro-galactic dose of Ivermectin was typically about three milligrams. The dose of Ivermectin, if you were not feeling well, you felt like you were exposed to COVID or you could come down with COVID or you were sick with COVID.
The sick with COVID was about, it's based upon weight, but the average person would take about 12 to 20 milligrams.
The cancer dose of Ivermectin, you can calculate on the member, the whole page of the member site. I give you the calculation. It's based upon kilogram weight. So you've got to convert your weight in pounds to kilogram.
Let's say you weigh 75 kilograms, then you would start with a half of a milligram per kilogram of weight. So if you weighed 75 kilograms, you would take 37.5.
There are about milligrams of Ivermectin a dose a day. That would be an initial starting cancer dose.
So lots of times I'll talk to people on the phone and they're saying I'm taking Ivermectin for my cancer. Oh, great. Well, it was prescribed by such and such doctor for my cancer and I'm excited about it.
What dose do you take it? 12 milligrams. That's not a cancer-treating dose. So the starting cancer-treating dose is one half of a milligram per kilogram of your weight.
So you've got to convert your weight to kilograms. And then divide that by half, and that would be your starting dose, which is much higher than the dose for COVID.
I mean, much higher dose than of a prophylactic dose.
So if I wasn't exposed to a bunch of people that were sick, therefore I'm thinking of a prophylactic dose.
Or if my cancer was in remission or if I did death cancer, personally, I wouldn't take it at all.
I would only take it if some crazy new virus was going around and I'm going to be exposed to it.
So I'm taking a prophylactic dose. Otherwise, I wouldn't use a medication. Any medication that way. Not just me.
Also, the health world is saying you should use talo as your fat instead of seed oils. But would this be harmful for someone who has had breast cancer because it involves animal proteins?
No, I would not say it's harmful. There's more and more information coming out of the inflammatory effects of seed oils.
And you could say that systemic inflammation is at least a piece of, at least a piece of all cancers, piece of all diseases, probably.
And you could make a valid argument that when our society in general was using large and talo as their fat source, as in society, there were no seed oils.
So we're only using butter and talo and lard in cooking. There really was no cancer. There was very little heart disease.
But heart disease and cancer, the two number one killers of the people in the Western world has skyrocketed since the use of seed oils.
Now, you could argue that, oh, well, there's other things that are involved with that. Yes, I would agree, toxic levels, et cetera. However, I think that using talo, which is the beef equivalent of lard, lard is made from pork fat, talo is made from beef fat, would be much healthier for you in cooking than using seed oils.
How do you stay close to the Lord when things are going bad? Well, to me, I think it's a whole lot easier for me to stay close to the Lord when things are going bad. My flesh is such that when things are going good, you tend to not need God as much.
I think the whole purpose of God allowing trials in your life is evidence that he loves us so much that he gives us trials so that we will have a greater dependence upon him.
It's when we do things in our own flesh and our own strength and our own self-ambition that we lose track of what is real important in life.
And we can lose track of our relationship with him. It's on the mountains that is the most dangerous. It's in the valleys that we hang on tighter to the Lord.
So my advice to someone going through difficult times is to allow it to drive you to a closer relationship with him, allow it to drive you to a greater level of dependence upon him.
Climb up on his lap and just allow him to snuggle with you and tell you how much he loves you and experience that he walks through those valleys with you.
And that's what you can, at least for me, that's what I can tell where my relationship is the strongest is when I'm in those valleys and that's where I'm the most thankful.
It's never fun, it's never easy. I'm not a masochist or a sadist, but it is through the valleys that it's through the difficult times.
My wife and I have always sought out difficult times to make ourselves too comfortable.
When we're too comfortable, we have to go, okay, what is it the Lord else wants us to do? I think the devil wants us to be the most comfortable.
But what else is the Lord has for us? Then I need to get on my knees and get in a prayer time for other people.
And it's the valleys that remind me of that. So that's where I'm the most encouraged.
There was a question that came in. Let's get to these questions. What did adaptogen help regulate ADHD or vasopressin?
Adaptogen maybe because adaptogens can affect your pituitary gland.
So it can affect your parathyroid.
No, if it would directly affect that. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I have to look up and see some studies on that.
I don't think so off of my head as I think of the physiology.
Last week, I asked about a comment on my ZRT results about methylation for hydroxy E2, which is an esterone derivative.
And you want to be to email you the report. Did you see it? Yes, I emailed you back to that. In fact, I ordered some ZRT kits. I like that report because of that.
So it gives you what you're talking about the Dutch test, which the ZRT test is a Dutch test, too. So it's a dried urine test as well, I believe.
And it gives you a couple extra markers that the Dutch brand test, the precision analytics test doesn't give you. And what is the four hydroxy E2?
So that's what I did like that. So I did email you back and say I like that test. So thank you.
Do you have any thoughts on red light therapy? Does it compliment the right or not? So yeah, I think the red light and green and blue light therapy can be beneficial.
I think we're red light therapy. So red light therapy is at a very specific frequency. I can't remember what it is like 300 and it's like 640 nanometers or something like that.
But it doesn't I do not believe red light therapy. It has a great physiological benefit below a few millimeters of the skin.
I'm not saying that any effect on the germ of the skin doesn't affect the core. There can be a reflex effect on the core.
But I think sometimes there's too much emphasis on red and green and blue light therapy. But I think it there can be benefit.
Does it compliment the right? Yeah, it can compliment the right. So you can do them together. You can do them at the same time. You can do it different times. There's no harm in doing light therapy. There's no harm in doing red light therapy.
So absolutely go for it. Recap my recent MRI showed a very small sub centimeter. It means less than one centimeter hyper intensities in my liver, which of course they said were probably assist, but recommended a contrast MRI to see more clearly.
The nurse practitioner from Simon men who did my consult said that I could get could get an ultrasound, which may show if there's any blood vessels. You agree with that.
Second, is there a right program that I could run during the day to see if I can get them to go away.
I don't know if there is a right program on the general program for cysts.
I have created one, though. So if you can send me an email, I can send you a flash drive with a program for cysts.
I created actually a number of years ago because I had a patient, a person contact me and had a what's called a giant cell tumor.
A giant cell tumor is the cell, the cell size is large. It doesn't mean the tumor is always large, but this person's tumor was 13, 13 or 15 centimeters.
Very large in their lower abdominal cavity and it was nonsurgical. And you know, it's a giant cell tumor is typically not malignant.
And they asked if the right would help that. Well, there isn't any programs for that. So I created one for that.
It's, it works out all cysts and they had an unbelievable result. It was, it shrank it down to the last time I talked to this person.
Maybe a year ago, shrank it down to three centimeters and it had stayed that way.
So I could send you that program.
That's the other question. We're doing an ultrasound show. If there is blood supply. If, if I don't know. So if, if the tumor, if the cyst, the lesion, better term, if the lesion is in the liver, what an ultrasound show that lesion.
Maybe, it depends on if it's behind the ribs. It depends on how visible it is. There's no harm or foul and tried.
You know, it's not invasive. And I think the nurse practitioner was trying to give you the least invasive.
The possibility. So I would agree that would be the least invasive regarding destroyed a solid mass. I also heard of photon beams in lieu of radiation treatment.
That's true, but photon beams are a type of radiation. So I think I have a blog post on the different, two different types of radiation.
And photon radiation is still radiation. And when it came out originally, it was thought to be a lot less damaging than the original radiation.
It hasn't exactly proven to be so, but I still think it's safer. So I have a blog post on explaining the differences.
There are a lipid test that shows the particle size and the fluffiness of the lipids in the blood. What do you call them? I think it's APOA and APOB. Yes.
So there is an expanded cardio panel that a person could do. I think it's on the Rupa, it's on our lab store as something like an expanded cardio panel where it gets into the size and the oxidation level of the different lipids.
So we're talking about lipids, we're talking about cholesterol and HDL cholesterol and LDL cholesterol, but then getting into the minutia of those are the APOA and B and the oxidized APOA and B and all that.
And that's the advanced cardio panel so you can look at something like that. I asked about these other things because I read a study that showed no increase in bioavailability with fat.
Oh, okay. What are you talking about? The fed bed is all.
I see you replied to my CMP results say that you liked their test better. So maybe you just replied to the wrong email. Sorry, sorry, maybe I did.
So at any rate, did you agree with the, yes, okay, so yes, I, the other comment that I had on that that I just remembered right now is it would be wise if if you would get a homocysteine level done.
I also want to, we should probably have a conversation because I also want to look at your genes again.
There's a new study that came up about the methylation response with certain gene. So I have to take another deeper dive into your genes.
It's not one that's normally shown in the whole genetic report. So I just said we get your genetic report. It's what 350 some pages now.
But if you're, but there's, there's, there's like 90,000 genes. So if we printed off the entire all your genes, it'd be well over a thousand pages.
So I could do a search for different genes in, in your software.
So your, if your homocysteine is consistently high, I think we do have your methyl groups, right.
So that would be the treatment for that. So if you have, if you're for methylated E2 to 4 hydroxy E2 is off that ratio is off, then you would add a methyl, add methyl groups.
Okay, that's good. So I guess we don't have to do the homocysteine that.
So that's what you would do. So the treatment for that would be to add some methyl groups. I know we're past our time, but go ahead if you guys got more questions.
And that's one of those things. So when you look at your astrogens and your methylated astrogens, that's another clue like looking at homocysteine.
You know, we've always said that you don't want to be taking too many methyl groups as a cancer patient, or we take a lot of exogenous methyl groups in like succulents.
Because excess methylation can turn off to our suppressor genes, and that's a major piece of the cause of why a person got cancer or why a person can get rid of cancer.
But again, now that kind of flips on its head a little bit when a person has elevated homocysteine, or we can see that they, this is another test that shows issues with the, with the ratio of difference.
You suggest no white bread, thoughts about sourdough.
Well, sourdough has other benefits in it, especially if you're making your own sourdough.
But again, you know, you know, access carbs like that, you know, are never in favor, but again, having some sourdough or having some butter, even if you're on a dairy-free diet like we talked last week.
You know, about a dairy-free diet, you know, could I have a little butter? Yes, you can.
So it's about balance. And so if you want a piece of sourdough, because you're a piece of sourdough, they're good to say it's eaten a piece of sourdough.
I remember I had a couple of years ago. He hasn't been on the Zoom for quite a while, but he's still alive.
He, I remember him begging me that if he could just have eat a hamburger because he was, he had prostate cancer and he was on a, had issues with a glutamate, was a driver until he was on a meat-free diet for the period of time.
And he was sticky. There was diet so well that he would refuse to even ever eat a hamburger. So I thought he was going to climb through the fold and kiss me when I told him he could have a hamburger once in a while.
So it's all about balance. So just keep that in mind.
So do you have any reservations about methyl-beta cyclo-destered? Yeah, I just don't know enough about them to comment about it. Salicylic acid is, is aspirin.
And that obviously has other issues with it with, with, with, being a basal dilator. And so you're going to be careful with too much of that.
So I don't know. I mean, maybe using something like that would be beneficial.
I just, I just don't have any experience with it. I missed the link of last week's Q&A and then I went to link to catch up and seen that the whole hour session isn't there just individual questions.
No, the whole hours there remember the all the zoom calls are going to be on our video channel now not on YouTube. YouTube hates us and they're taking down everything.
Okay, I just mentioned, Ben, Ben is all I mentioned, I remecting. If we put this video on YouTube, they take down our whole channel because we already got two strikes against us in one more strike, they're going to take down our whole channel.
So we have not been able to put up a new video on YouTube for the last several weeks. So a pretty similar YouTube video channel is going to be gone.
So we've already got everything transferred over to our own video channel. So that's videos dot cutters clinic dot com.
So all the videos will be there and they're based on it'll say just like the title of this zoom space 01 and last week should be oh slash 08 slash 2025.
That's the way it'll be titled.
If homelessness team doesn't decrease my functional doctor wants me to take something called methyl care.
I want to look up what that is, what brand that is so that just might be other different methyl groups.
Okay, everybody, thanks for being on tonight.
Blessings to all of you will be praying for all of you.
Have a blessed day and we'll see you next week.
Bye bye.